[Music]
hi and welcome to episode 139 of the
currently daily Google cloud platform
podcast we're here on the sheriff floor
next and as always I'm here with Melanie
how you doing Melanie hi mark
we are almost there it's actually
technically the day after day three it's
the next day yes yes but some pretty
amazing I'm doing okay I'm I'm still
soldiering on you're pushing trim yeah
today was pretty amazing
today was the developer keynote a lot of
our teammates who are on stage you thing
you know Kelsey yeah just killing it
just killing it all the things you can
do is developer yeah you should check
out the keynote it was really really
cool they did some amazing stuff a lot
of life code a lot of life code which
it's wonderful yeah I know I Adam was
saying like let's show ya not tell ya so
yeah it was a good day and we have a
couple more interviews that we have done
won't open at NEX that we're gonna
showcase now so let's go ahead and do
that let's do it we have joining with us
Stephanie wet though and Vivian San who
are both here from tectonic ax thank you
both for joining us today thank you for
a mighty man thank you for a so tell us
a little bit about who you are and what
you're doing my name is Stephanie wet
though I was born and raised in Southern
California I moved up here after college
and I lived in the suburbs didn't really
like it sounds pretty exciting sometimes
and I only wanted to be independent girl
by myself and so moved out here when I
started college after college it wasn't
a non-profit sector for a little bit and
then code kept bugging me a little bit
and then it kept bugging me actually all
my undergrad and then after college too
and then I applied to a couple of
programs cuz I like a way like this you
know and so
ended up applying tectonic ax and now
I'm here nice cool amphibian my name is
Vivian and I'm a service co- and I grew
up in the Tenderloin district so it's
pretty much part of like the tech hub
and everything and I honestly have never
even thought about going into tech I was
a chemistry graduate from UC Davis and
you know of course advice but four years
of college getting a degree I'm gonna
like come out of it feel like I'm
totally gonna be a chemist there's no
way but I mean it's where how I even
came upon like being in tech you know
cuz there's something that I never even
thought over something that anyone even
introduced to me but it was weird
because like the day that I came out I
actually saw tectonic applier and I was
like you know what I'm gonna give this a
shot like if like I could do something
as scary as that then like I could do
this and for those who don't know what
is tectonic ax so tectonic ax is
basically like a nonprofit organization
that is providing free technical
training to local woman and non-binary
adults and basically just giving them
the opportunity to learn these relevant
tech skills and without having to worry
about you know the cost of it and
especially if there are mothers they
don't have to worry about childcare just
giving them a safe place and we're gonna
community to just learn and my
understanding is you're both from the
first class right yeah and you just just
finished yeah last week last week yeah
everything's going so fast well I know
it usually does are you in the process
now of doing the whole like preparing
and looking for jobs so amazing thing
that happened is that tectonic was able
to provide everyone a placement with a
partner that's great yeah so we all have
internships starting either next week on
Monday or a couple of weeks after that
oh wow yeah so it looks like they
provide tech apprenticeships can you
tell us about like what that looks like
and what you actually end up doing when
you're in the program I would say like
the first three months is just really
just learning all about everything about
JavaScript like learning it religiously
no but really just the first three
months it's just learning a fundamentals
really and then the next three message
is doing all projects and just building
off of like what we learned and being
able to apply a working in groups and
also working independently so just
getting a little bit of best of both
worlds nice and I know there's also
support under for people with low income
so they like we ride laptops things like
that as well yeah so they provide if you
need
paper right a laptop if you need you
know some help financially they also
provide the living stipend for the
apprentice nice and where were you
starting it's internships or it's where
you starting internships it's so it's
Mixpanel
so a bit of a competitor with google
analytics we will accept that yeah I'm
starting at Redfin so their real estate
company yeah yeah so this is great so
we're at next yeah and you've been here
for two days it's like the third day as
we speak how has it been what have you
seen that you've been excited about I
think this is like literally the biggest
conference we've ever been to because
they're only so used to just being in
like one building but this is like
spread out between like five different
places and it's pretty crazy but like I
mean it's just insane how much
technologies are out there and like how
much they're releasing so quickly I mean
it's also like really overwhelming even
that was really exciting because you
know especially now has worked like
developers we we know like all these
tools that are out there and you know we
know that we can take what we've learned
from here and be able to you know tell
our companies about it be able to
leverage our knowledge and being able to
contribute I think that's like really
the most amazing thing is just being
able to feel that way yeah I think also
just how welcoming it is to I think
sometimes we take for granted that we're
in San Francisco and then we meet other
people from other parts of the world and
they're like oh my gosh like you know
they're taking pictures and for nice for
me like I kind of been to other
conferences to and it is this is
probably one of the biggest ones where
it combines a lot of people because it's
like developers marketing cells like all
these like people that come from
different backgrounds in text so it's
pretty interesting to just see the mesh
of it but when we talk to them like oh
my god like you're from like you live
here and I'm like yeah like this is
amazing you know you like you around
everything I'm like yeah it's really
cool you know
so it's interesting just to meet other
diverse people and just kind of get the
other perspective because sometimes I
think we do take for granted we're
around here and it was asking you before
we started that were there any sessions
that you went to that you were excited
about are there any sessions that you
wanted to mention that you saw and found
very interesting yeah so I was talking
about the I am remarkable workshop
that's happening upstairs and
second for Miss Kanye West and it was
just very like I came in they're just
kind of like oh it sounds cool you know
like let me see what it's all about and
then they came out you with stats or
like hey like you your remark was so
it's a workshop targeted towards women
but it's also for everyone it's just
kind of like kind of change your mindset
of how you think about yourself because
with women and specifically they are
more prone to be like put down by both
men and women so if they ever like are
bragging about themselves when they say
their accomplishments out loud or if
they speak up or anything like that like
they're more likely to be like she's
talking too much or like she's like
bragging about her silver and then like
so you're getting hit not only from like
the male side of it but also you're your
own like colleagues that as women you
know and it's like and then on top of
that we also are more prone to talk
about ourselves too like we don't want
to like come off that way so then we
start putting our own self self like oh
we should have probably shined that much
and like just kind of put our
accomplishments a little bit down so
they gave us a good like just background
on it and just where these stats were
coming from and then after that we did
the actual workshop where they gave us a
piece of paper where you write down like
all the things that you're remarkable
because of so it was interesting just to
see like how people get stumped and how
people were also very positive ones that
they were able to like write the whole
page down to say I'm remarkable because
I'm a software engineer you know I'm
remarkable because they speak two
languages or three languages or four
languages you know I'm remarkable
because I volunteered on my spare time
here you know and like just all these
things that come out that you don't
really realize that you're doing and
that you are remarkable because you know
and so some people were going really
strong and some people were like stumped
at one point because we just I guess
we're prone to not like they were saying
we're not prone to really think that way
you know and we need to change that and
you know look in the mirror be self
positive talk to yourself and say like
you know you are remarkable you're like
yeah you you're beautiful you're
positive like you know you're amazing
person you know change to that
perspective a little bit or more and so
it was just amazing you know I was
almost able to write that whole page at
the end but kind of fell short but it's
okay you know I'm gonna try to do it and
it's a good thing to do you know when
you go to your teams and stuff like that
and you're even your friends you know
like make everyone change the
perspective of how awesome they are
thanks Vivian any sessions that stood
out for you yeah I mean I wasn't for
sure was one of them too we also went to
one where they were talking about like
accessibility and inclusion and I
thought that was really awesome because
it's like you don't you know especially
when you're making talks or you know
making meetings that's not something
that you purposely try to do and not
make it inclusive for all your employees
but it's just something that does happen
but it's like I found it so amazing how
there was so much detail that goes into
it to try to like you know make everyone
feel safe and make everyone could
include it and I felt like you know
especially for us it's like what we were
told is like when we come into this you
know we can learn how to take the core
knowledge that you know people will you
know tell us and we can learn online and
stuff but you can't really teach people
perspective and I think for us
especially coming in from like
non-technical backgrounds and low-income
families like and you know communities I
think that showed us that you know we
could contribute and I felt like you
know just because of that talk it made
me feel more comfortable going in saying
like yes you know I can make a
contribution that I could be a strength
to this company and I thought that was
amazing just to hear them say that
that's great awesome have you played
with any of like the showcase demos or
anything else around here as well not
yet but we're going today that's what's
next for you yeah we've been going to
like a lot of the talks the talks and
they're been like walking around we
haven't even gone to I think there's a
couple work shows that I want to go to
today at the hotel so I went to one in
the Metreon in the theater which was
kind of interesting and then like
there's some of the hotel says like
that's just huge you know I know we
actually before we started to we were
talking about how you were surprised
that there's so much that Google has in
terms of products and services yeah I
didn't know it was like an AWS Macy's
like Amazon I was like whoa you can do
everything that Amazon does too you know
like hosting websites doing all these
things I was like whoa I didn't know all
of this and I was like amazed when I was
hearing the keynote speakers speak about
like all of these products are coming
out or like they're revamping and
everything that was like whoa I need to
get on Google oh you know more you know
good job here is done we're done now
last question I want to ask you both is
coming from this program is there any
advice that you have for those who are
getting into tech so at the end of our
last week so Michelle made us Michelle
the CEO she made us reflect and you know
write down like advice that you probably
have for future apprentices you know and
I kind of thought about myself and I was
like what would I want to hear you know
in the beginning of this program to make
it a little bit easier and everything
like that and so we did write down a
couple of things and one of those things
to me was or to the Future ones it's
like hey this is gonna be tough so make
sure you do like prepare you know like
make sure you are strict with your
schedule you know like you are gonna
have to really focus right now you're
gonna have to be frugal too because it's
long process you're not working right
now and so make sure that you're very
disciplined one it's okay to say no you
know it's okay to say no to like other
activities like birthdays like all these
festivities they're gonna be there still
the next year and so right now it's you
need to focus on you and that was the
one main thing that I was like it's okay
to say no and it's okay to focus on this
and like you need to be a little bit
selfish you know just need to focus on
yourself right now that's great and I
would say it's okay you know to feel
scared because I went into it I was so
terrified I was like this is I don't
know anything and I don't know what to
expect and everything was just so like
unknown I think I would just tell the
future princess that you know it's okay
to feel scared and I think just allowing
yourself to feel vulnerable and the fact
that you do feel scary I think that's
actually a really good thing because
it's is telling you that you're actually
trying to push yourself to learn
something new and like trying to change
your life and I think that's okay like
you feel scared it might actually be a
good thing especially if there is a No
More cohort that coming in I would tell
them that you know we need more women we
need more diversity we need more
inclusion and by doing this you are
helping to I guess I was Misha what's a
bridge the tech gap it's actually just
being able to put more perspectives out
there and you know you are gonna be
someone who's gonna be part of this
community to change the world I think I
would add on to like
yeah please you are like we all became
very close we're very strong and it's
like make sure like you are all going
through similar things so we talked to
one another speak to one another you're
gonna go through a lot and so make sure
you have that support system because you
know maybe your parents or anyone
doesn't really know what you're going
through right now it's just a different
background or maybe even friends you
know so you guys are all gonna become
very strong and like make sure you keep
that together and like rely on one
another on your community you can build
your community and places like this to
give you opportunity to to expand that -
yeah well thank you very much for
joining us and sharing your experiences
we really appreciate it yeah thank you
guys thank you very fun super excited we
have two really amazing people coming to
join us today
Liz your last name function was going
well I had it right in my head and I got
it wrong Nikita goona excellent thank
you so much both of you for joining us
today thank you for joining yes thank
you for having us
you're granted grab y'all off the floor
it's like please please come on - vodka
so you both three very different things
but Liz why don't you tell us a little
bit about yourself and tell us about
what you do and stuff sure so I am a
customer reliability engineer and I help
GCP customers build and operate reliable
services mgcp
so that mean volved anything from
teaching them how to run incidents to
teaching them how to monitor services
and how to architect their services
better and we've done a podcast with you
previously - yes you have yes we have
Nikita what do you do so I work it right
add I am at kubernetes maintainer
I work on all things extensibility of
kubernetes and mark knows a lot about it
yeah I like to do everything open source
basically basically the work that you do
makes okones possible awesome and we
like open source and we have an episode
coming out on a Gunness and a couple
weeks so Nikita what are you enjoying
about next oh I love next so that was
was it in the booth in the booth area
and the most interesting part was
looking at how everyone is using Google
cloud and the one thing I noticed is
that almost all companies are using GCC
peo gke very different ways so I think
it was pretty cool like going to all
bullets and figuring out how they were
using it understanding more about it and
then Liz I know you just did a talk and
you're finally free of the talk how was
your talk what would you talk about
so yesterday I got to share with
everyone a bunch of early access staff
ever features that enable people to do
their operations more like essary using
secular tooling so specifically how do
you improve your measurement how do you
improve your time to detect instance how
do you improve your time to respond to
incidents using really cool stuff that
we're finally getting to talk about so
my favorite thing about next has been
getting to release all this cool stuff
and see how people react to it that's
really cool
we talk a lot about open source I think
pretty much all over the place Nikki
yeah involved with open source for
really long time how did you end up
there it's not written a really long
time it's like a year
a long time well I just graduated so I
got involved through a program called
the google Summer of Code so it's that
Google pay students to work on open
source projects during the summer and I
started contributing to kubernetes that
way and well I just contribute a lot
right now
so that's my open source really nice Liz
what's your experience with the open
source world what are your perspectives
in terms of where things are at what
you're excited about I'm really excited
that there is so much interesting work
happening with open census with
kubernetes where we're starting to see a
lot of the things that we've been doing
inside of Google for a long time be
accessible and interoperable with people
outside of Google that's been super
awesome because it means that people
don't have to reinvent the wheel over
and over they can just plug into things
that people have already built and
that's really awesome thanks open senses
tribute to at some point maybe you'll
get to it after next we also did a
podcast on open yeah I'm sure you don't
need it but if you need introductions
I'm more that's really cool and I know
you work on the extension part of
kubernetes what are some cool extensions
that you've seen oh I think there's
something called as agonist
I think it's also covered and the GCV
podcast so it is a bit yeah so you
should definitely check it out yeah
anything else that others and stuff I
work on I think like operators are
really the kind of exciting bit I've
been related to extensibility of the
kubernetes api and I think that like
lots of operators out there so I think I
would definitely say like the operative
read all of over plugging all the things
and Olivia also bring this back it's
quite an interesting inner mix of
discussion but Liz I know we had you on
like we said with Seth and we talked
about esterase and DevOps and my
understanding is you guys just had a
another episode that came out in terms
of the video series that you're working
on is that right we have a new set of
five episodes coming out in late August
ah so you have let me vermin sorted them
last week I saw some announcement I
thought it had already come but I
apparently not yet so it's coming out in
August in late August late August nice
and any specific highlights that you can
mention now yeah we have a really packed
agenda we're talking about things like
how do you respond to incidents or how
do you set up your alerting so that you
can actually reasonably defend your
service level objectives rather than
finding out like you know hey we broke
it but we didn't find out until it was
too late okay I know you both have to go
you both have meetings before you go
favorite thing you've seen it next so
far no it was really cool I love your
talk it was it was funny I like that
thank you okay she had that Liz favorite
thing I have to say the thing from this
morning of the mini teeth use the edge
tip use that was really exciting to see
that you know these chips of silicon
that Google's manufacturing will be in a
whole bunch of devices nice well thank
you so much for coming and taking some
time to chat with us we really
appreciate it yeah absolutely thank you
for having us I just came for the
chocolate yes we have chocolate please
have chocolate please take the chocolate
meze
so it's great that rubber Kubus is
joining us he is a fellow developer
advocate and alumni podcast attendee I
think I think week for week you've been
pretty busy here at next what are you
been up to
yeah like first of all thank you for
having me again like after we at the
podcast that good maybe maybe yeah it
has been really exciting so I think like
what is maybe sometimes not seeing that
there's a lot of work that goes in by
the DAT more general like a lot of like
Google teams into making this conference
a reality so I was involved personally
in building some of the showcases so in
particular two of the showcases that I
wouldn't was involved in the cloud
spanner booth or showcase I was involved
in the creatives as well as building
part of the demos and for the storage
and database one as well and
she's not of work you can imagine don't
you just push a button and make it worse
that's all you need
Naoko so that's actually a funny thing
like I think it's not the majority of
work is not actually the coding or the
technical part of this the majority of
the work is actually getting the
messaging right we want to have that the
attendee has a good experience that they
understand what we want to achieve of
the showcase that they get an intrinsic
experience into the showcase and
creating this kind of narrative this
course of the work I would have to say
and fine-tuning it and then getting it
into reality is the heavy lifting for
creating a showcase so tell us about the
showcases you've had a hand in tell us
what those are all about so the first
one is the cloudspinners showcase where
we have kind of like two substations in
the showcase so one of them is what we
call the cloud spanner kaleidoscope
which is a really cool looking kind of
installation with some mirrors and the
display and some buttons and handles and
wrenches which is the in British English
it's actually spanner is a wrench in the
nietzermann what we wanted to show there
is the aspect of manageability in cloud
spanner that it's very easy to get your
own instance and scaling it in and out
and we wanted to show you that it's done
in four clicks and you basically choose
the name you choose what configuration
you want to have we wanna show you so
how many notes you want to have and then
you click OK and you have your own
instance so very easy so the substation
2 is where I actually show how easily
and how quickly the cloud spanner is
scaling in an hour so I have a demo
where you can produce some throughput
some reads and writes against loud
spanner and then you can scale it in and
out you can scale the notes and you see
how quickly spanner is load-balancing
and your latency is go down again and
things like that it's really cool thing
I encourage everybody to check it out
cool well so what have you seen it next
outside of you know what you've been
working on that you're really excited
about
so there's unfortunately not a lot of
things I also had two talks that I had
to prepare off and exactly exactly so
the thing is or maybe I guess there are
a lot of people like me in the sense but
most people maybe not seeing that from
the outside but I'm a notoriously
procrastinator so I'm probably the best
in my life in procrastinating till the
deadline is looming so I'm usually the
one who is late with slides and
preparing to like late hours and stuff
like that no exactly no one is doing
that so I have been pretty much been
involved in like preparing for my talks
to deliver a good experience also to the
attendees they are coming here to get
some information and to get the best out
of the session so I want to give them
the best of me so I invested a lot of
time into perfecting my talks and really
have a good experience for the attendees
I got to walk a little bit on the
showcase floor in Moscone West today and
one experience which I really liked was
the cloud function experience big cannon
and you can shoot your cloud function
now into the cloud which is amazing so I
encourage everybody also to check out
the cloud function special case and
what's quality best
actually it's worth noting right you
just talked about like how much time and
effort goes into the showcases how much
time and effort goes into your
presentations but that's just this one
showcase and one present like we have
over 500 400 presentations and how many
showcases on the show floor I don't know
60 70 80 I don't know it's like it's a
lot yes that's mean that's a lot of
effort it's kind of my point yes to put
on a show this size that's spanning what
six buildings yeah and how many
attendees I heard it once or 25,000 yeah
something on that yeah and how does this
compare to last year it is actually so I
have been with cloud in particular
Google cloud for three years and four
months now and I have experience I think
this is my fourth next time
and it has been a tremendous growth I
think last year around seven to ten
thousand I don't know the exact number
the year before that was two hours yeah
so it basically tripled almost
quadrupled in size and now it doubled in
size again but it's just crazy how it
crew IO this year is it has been the
biggest largest conference for Google so
far and what I've seen that's amazing so
far as yeah this is my third next and I
mean this is the biggest but I actually
genuinely believe this is the best next
and I know you did the podcast last year
do you do it the year before that yeah
Wow yeah we've been doing the podcast on
the show floor for yeah yeah yeah we
didn't know what we were getting into in
the first year but still here we are
here we are it's wonderful well Rob
anything else you wanted to share with
the folks back home around next around
things they should look for I hope
everybody enjoys their experience here
please reach out to us and the podcast
team if you have any question also we
love to hear positive and critical
feedback so if there's anything really
think where we can improve please let us
know but also show us the law basically
where we do well we want to hear that we
need that as well to basically find the
energy to do even better next for you
next year and follow me and twitter at
Hofstra ste so I think I take a break
for a while that's acceptable awesome
well thank you so much for joining us
thank you for having me all right Cheers
thanks again for everybody who came out
for today as well as everyone who's come
for the last two days we've really
appreciated being able to talk to a
different you know partners and stood
and Alliance people all the
relationships just getting a sense of
the perspectives and the interests and
what everybody's been experiencing yeah
we appreciate that I also want to just
take a second and say this because this
is my first next the podcast oh yeah I
know mark we were talking about it
before offline that this is your third
yep yeah so you and Prince last year in
the year before and say this is like old
hat for you yep totally you say one of
the things that I've observed that has
been really impressive is just how many
people have come by and I'm really
grateful for that for the listeners who
stopped by to say thank you so thank you
for saying thank you cuz well it means a
lot to hear that this has been very
helpful for you and I also want to give
a shout out to James who's been with us
for awhile who's been helping to edit
this oh my god yeah who's been
incredible especially with what we've
been doing for this week yes and more
recently Jennifer and Trey you know have
been also incredible so we're not just
doing this by ourselves you know I have
a couple of other people who have been
phenomenal and making sure that this
actually is getting done yeah there have
been killing it doing daily episodes of
super hard work and setting all up the
interviews and everything we've been
doing it next it's been like non-stop
while we've been here but we couldn't
have done it without the support of all
the people behind us so thanks thanks
very very much
and then mark thanks for making this so
easy this has been fantastic and and
bringing me along for the ride I thank
you for joining me this has been an
absolute delight in a pleasure yeah I
think that's a wrap for us for next yep
and we will have another episode like
always next week you will get to hear
about container security to give that a
little TF but yeah outside of that mark
you're going anywhere you're gonna do
anything sleep yeah I'm gonna sleep
sleeping is good yeah yeah yeah I
definitely need to recover fantastic now
it's been a great event thank you all
for listening and yeah we'll actually
see you all next week we'll see you next
week
[Music]